SKRRRRATTAR DU
I gotta be quiet guys...
Where am I?
Doko desuka?
*Swedish man who lives in the UK speaking Japanese*
That's right everyone
I am in Nippon
Did you guess it from my Neko headphones?
That's right
I'm somewhat of a Japaneseヽ(^◇^*)/
*whisper* I gotta be really quiet this time
The rule is simple
You laugh, You lose
And this time
Bringing new meaning to the game
Cause I dunno if my neighbours will be pissed off
So I'm trying to keep it down
It's aways so awkward recording in a new space
This is a new setup
It's a bit more iNtiMate, don't ya think?
Don't you like this?
Feels more special
The really hardest part of this challenge
Is the fact that I don't have any G-fuel
That's right, I forgot to pack it
How am I gonna get through this
Without G-fuel, this is impossible
I know
But we're going to have to do this together
We're on the same level now
Let's freaking do this
*gasp* NOOOooooooAHHHHHHHHHH
*gasp* NOOOooooOOOOooAHHHHHHHHHH
Oh God
I have already lost
Awwwww
Could this be the first time I ever lose
You laugh, You lose?
Oh my god
You know, maybe it's a nice place down there
*gasp* NOOOooooOOOOooAHHHHHHHHHH
[pewd's cute laugh]
It's a lake in berryessa
It's a reservoir for a dam
And the giant vortex is a drain
To prevent the dam from flooding
This is so sad
Can we got some Fs in the chats
And smash like on this video, if you...
Don't want ducks to go down giant vortexes
I expect this to get a billion likes
How do I make videos?
Someone remind me please
Your jokes have always been stale Felix
Nothing has changed
SKRRTFSFSFK (ew)
I'm close now
[incoherent grunts]
Oh god
I said oh god again
Same reactions just over and over
Now this is the kind of real enthusiasm
When I ask for a bro fist
Ha just kidding
You broke your screen for nothing *beeps*
How is your screen not broken yet?
Pound it real
For once
Oh god
Give me your hardest bro fist!
Damn that felt good
I'll buy you a new a new monitor Cyranek
I'm sorry
You got trolled Cyranek
Jesus christ
You knew it was coming
Is it still playing?
Poor monitor
NOOOOO
Don't do it!
Stop it!
You call that a bro fist Cyranek?
It should have at least gone to space
That wouldn't bro fist anyone
That was the weakest bro fist I've ever seen in my life
I'm not gonna buy you a new monitor
Cause it's clearly still working
Pathetic
Try harder next time
On an all new Sunday Special
Phil: "Now Ben I know you like to say
Facts don't care about your feelings
But, I wanna tell you some facts about your feelings"
(lookit 'em faces lol)
How is this real? What is this?
When did
*licks lips*
See I can't
Oh god I can't review this
They're gonna--
copystrike it
(pls put why r u running meme)
Tune in this week
Is that real?
Oh my god, thats's amazing
On an all new Sunday Special
Phil: "Now Ben I know you like to say
facts don't care about your feelings
but I wanna tell you some facts about your feelings"
I can't tell if it's real
It must be real, that's amazing
God damn I
I wanna review that episode so bad
I can't do anymore Dr. Phil videos
Fs in the chat guys
Fs in the chat
Okay I've seen this
I saw it on H3 podcast
It's goddamn amazing
Lemme just preface by saying that
Why'r you on the floor?
*muffled*
Use the restroom
Sorry
Sorry about that
Oopsie
OoOOoopsiEe
Oh my god
America everyone
This does not happen anywhere else
Maybe in Japan actually
Oh sorry
I dropped my contact lens
You're wearing glasses
Sorry
SoRRryY
Nobody animals...
(lo and behold for u head/earphone users)
AAAAAAAAAHHHHH
Animals when they have something on their  head
But can't get it
AAAAAHHHHH
Jesus christ
I can't tell tell if I'm the only one laughing at these
They're so goddamn terrible
AHHHHHHH
I mean Ah! Thank you Marv for the 250
What happened to her?
Wasn't she the girl that used to go like
*high-pitched voice* No stop, stop being stooopp
Or like
*GirlDiePie* sTop bEiNg sO mEAn
She had us fooled all along
Jesus christ
Oh I love these
Mama, you'll never believe what happened
[retorted bgm playing]
You Laugh, You Sad
My god
Jesus christ
OOOOOOOOHHHHHH
Oh my god that's genius!
Oh my god
OOOHH MY GOD THAT'S GENIUS!
What if we used 100% of our brains?
My god, they figured it out
Life hacks that actually work
Incredible
Ahh I loved that
That's amazing
You get him
He's gonna pay the price
You guys are cruel
What are you doing? (ಥ﹏ಥ)
Oh my god
Oh my gosh!
Pewd: Is that his Xbox?
NO
That's his X...
*mumbled scream*
Pewd: *high-pitched* That is an Xbox--
--Oh no
NOOOO
*Evil Laugh*
BILL!
Oh god, I've seen this
(what the fudge is she doing ergh >:-( )
What is wrong with this girl?
Ew
Disgusting
Now I can never sit on a
I literally just sat on an airplane seat
This changes everything
It's like one thing to do it
It's another thing to film yourself doing it
Thanos when Ant-Man dives inside his *bleeps*
Awww
I can't wait for meme review
There's so many good Thanos
The anus memes
Oh my god
These memes, I swear to god
Just... What is this?
Karen took the kids
Good
Just get it over w...
Oh my god
Oh god Karen please I just want them back
I made a mistake, I'm sorry I love you
Please...
People have way too much spare time
Oh my god Grandayy you too?
Really Grandayy?
What are you going to do then?
What is this?
Herobama
Really?
Watch out behind you it's a creeper!
No, Herobama is...
Ok
Alright
That's not bad
When you see it
You're gonna go
Ahhhh
My god just stop these please
They're not funny
And they're not good
And they're not creative
Oh my god, it's the best meme
I have ever seen in my life
My life
What is this?
Jacksfilms
Bro Fist
Bridge?
Lasagna?
Stop
Stop it.
I'm actually hungry
I could go for some lasagna right now
To all you guys hating on me
Because I have an Android
There's noting wrong with Android
We have the best quality
Shut up!
Stop
I refuse to look at this
🐗
Oh my god
I sent lasagna into space
To save PewDiePie
Ft. Mr. Beast
That's one big ball
Oh my god
Incredible
So that's gonna take about two hours
To get into space
Oh my god
That's insane
Jesus
That's a good shot
Damn
So are they gonna eat it
Or what?
Oh my god
That's funny
Awww
Hang on I need to just...
Awwww
Awww
Thank you Pro Gamer J
Very cool
Jesus christ
When is it gonna end
So I get to work this morning
And normally the first thing I saw to my co-worker
Is, Hey guys! How's it going?
Well one of my co-workers decided to ask me today
Hey dude are you into fitness?
And I was like yeah dude, what's up man?
And he's like
Fit-n-this whole weaner in your mouth
I said
WHY WOULD YOU ASK ME THAT?!
Aw
Alright well,
I think that's it for this week's
Meme Review
I need help
Someone send me help
And G-fuel
For that matter
Thank you guys for watching
I'm gonna go and explore Nihon
Hope you guys had a good time today
If you want to support this amazing channel
Which is clearly putting a lot of time and effort
Into making the best videos
As I possibly could
Then support and get some epic merch
And that's it for me for n...
Marzia?
What were you doing?
You got a snack?
I didn't even notice it
But I'm...
What am I doing...
Ok
Alright
Fine
Bro Fist ^‿^
At 100 million
See you guys tomorrow
Bye
Tuber Simulator
Is now so relevant
That it's got a brand new mini game!
Craniac!
Drop the crane and get fresh items
Only available in the washing machine like game
And you say there's more?
Of course there is!
New knowledge perks
New quests
And new Pixilings
And legs
Guys
Legs